What's going on guys?
Today we're learning English with Finding Nemo.
So, I'm Ethan, your RealLife English fluency coach.
And I grew up watching this movie.
I watched it countless times as a kid.
It's definitely a Pixar classic that anyone from the United
States or I'd say anyone from around the world
probably knows. And it even stars the
iconic voice of comedian Ellen DeGeneres.
Now, the scene that we've chosen for you
today is perfect because it is packed with
vocabulary related to the sea and sea animals.
It is great for learning how to tell a story in English
and you even get to practice listening
to both American and Australian accents.
By the way, this week we are celebrating hitting
2 million subscribers here on YouTube.
It's really incredible!
So, to celebrate and to thank you, we have something really special to share with you in just a little bit.
Now, let's head under the sea
with Finding Nemo.
Hey guys! Let me just make a quick interruption
to say that we just recently
hit 2 million subscribers!
It is insane! I still cannot believe it!
And we are just so grateful to all of you and all of your support over the last few years in building this channel.
Really, all of your support means
that we can help more and more people
from all around the world to go beyond
the classroom and live their English.
Helping people to not just see it as a
dry and boring school subject,
but as something fun that
they actually look forward to learning.
And helping less and less people to give up,
and more and more to succeed
and love every step of the journey.
So, to thank you for all of your support
in helping us to reach this tremendous milestone ,
we want to help you to take your next
huge step on your journey to English fluency.
So, just for the next week we are offering you
an incredible 49% discount on our
Fluent with Friends course.
Wouldn't you love it if this time, next year,
you could understand your favorite series and
movies in English even without the subtitles?
And wouldn't it be incredible if you could master
native connected speech
just like we've shown you in this lesson?
Well, one of our students, Jenny,
says that thanks to our Fluent with Friends course,
she can now communicate freely
when she travels abroad and even in her daily life.
Well, to learn more about the course
and how you can get Fluent with Friends,
just click up here or down
in the description below.
And to get your 49% discount remember to use
the code 2million at checkout.
But, hurry — this offer is only available
for a few more days.
Now, let's get back to
our lesson with Finding Nemo.
All right!  I hope you've had a lot of fun
with this lesson with Finding Nemo!
And, hey, if you're ready take
your English to the next level,
and be able to understand your
favorite movies and series
even without the subtitles,
then, I want to invite you to check out
our Fluent with Friends course.
And, remember to use that coupon code 2million
to get a huge 49% discount at checkout.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom
and LIVE your English.
Aww Yeah!